bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct on passe tout de suite au
sommaire de cette édition
ils sont sauvés rétrogradé au classement
par la fédération française de foot us
les templiers d'elancourt ont dû jouer
ce samedi un match de barrage pour
finalement se maintenir dans l'élite 80
voitures centenaire s'étaient regroupés
devant le château de rambouillet ce
dimanche pour la troisième édition du
paris rambouillet immersion dans un
rallye qui offre une autre vie au mythe
de l'asphalté d'avant guerre il
s'appelle cyril jouan il est arbitre de
tennis et officiers il ya quelques jours
en tant que juge de ligne à roland
garros c'est notre portrait de la
semaine est évidemment comme d'habitude
l'essentiel des résultats du week-end en
fin d'émission mais tout de suite place
à notre page spéciale foot us
je le disais dans le sommaire de cette
émission les templiers avait été un
sanctionné il ya quelques semaines par
une irrégularité sur l'enregistrement
d'une licence d'un joueur en course pour
le titre a à priori les templiers
d'elancourt ont été rétrogradé au
classement du championnat de france
élite et ont dû jouer un match de
barrage pour finalement se maintenir
dans ce championnat alors qu'il était en
course pour les playoffs et le président
du club georges agostinho et est présent
sur le plateau du 7-8 sport pour
débriefer cette rencontre un petit peu
sous haute tension ce samedi soir
bonsoir à vous de l'horloge merci d'être
là alors une première réaction après
bassett cette victoire ce samedi soir
qui était essentiel pour l'avenir du
club tout à fait si tu es complètement
ils sont essentiels où on va dire que
les gars ils ont fait le job mais ils
ont fait un peu la mort dans l'âme mais
voilà ils ont fait leur job ils ont fait
ce qu'ils avaient à faire sont plus quoi
sont plus
l'essentiel est assuré un moratoire 24 à
13 face à amiens je vous propose
d'ailleurs georges de regarder le résumé
le compte rendu de ce match sous tension
avec des images de jonathan ville malgré
l'enjeu les templiers début de cette
rencontre pour leur survie dans l'élite
face à amiens avec le frein à main
verrouillé sans vraiment être mobilisés
comme encore assommés par leur
rétrogradation au classement
la tension mais on doit pas
en je pense qu'on est largement
supérieure on ne va pas se mettre dans
les positions c'est me voilà je pense
que les gars ont bien pris un petit coup
au moral
la suite aux décisions qui ont été
prises et du coup un peu moins présent
aux entraînements et sert à ça s'est
ressenti ce soir c'est une nouvelle fois
les attaquants supersonique élan
courtois qui vont débloquer la situation
avec en premier rôle jérôme laisse
croire sur 7 passes courtes de shon
shelton une nouvelle preuve du potentiel
des templiers
quand il accélère peu de défense résiste
face à de valeureux spartiates son
compère de l'attaqué jonathan avec moi
ce ne veut pas du second rôle dans ce
dernier acte de la saison et inscrit un
doublé pour mettre à l'abri l'encours
d'un rotor amiénois les templiers
s'impose finalement 24 13 et assurent
leur maintien dans l'élite
on a des matches à jouer et à gagner ça
a été fait donc on est content ça permet
à notre équipe de réserve de monter de
division qu'ils sont contents aussi on
assuré love le maintien c'est ce qui
comptait ce sens les templiers sont
désormais tournés vers leur grand
objectif de la saison décroché la ligue
des champions la victoire on a senti un
peu toute l'amertume de votre entraîneur
un samedi soir qu'il il était un petit
peu bougon que mal par rapport à
d'habitude
c'est vraiment et tous à peu près dans
le même état vous donc je le disais tout
à l'heure vous avez été rétrogradé c'est
assez rare ce genre de sanctions au
niveau du championnat de france élite de
foot us pour en fait une licence non
conformes
expliquez-nous un petit peu ce qu'il
s'est passé la licence se bat là les
transferts sont
on a passé un dernier transfert le 31
octobre et il s'avère que sur le
règlement c'est 30 octobre c'est pas la
fin du mois c'est 30 octobre donc nous
on a pensé parce que le règlement ont
fait 240 pages dont il est appelé à
pessah on savait que c'était forme top
prono fin octobre 31 31 jours il a fait
des émules 30 octobre donc pourquoi pas
quoi mais bon alors précisé c'est
qu'auparavant les saisons précédentes il
y a quelques années encore c'était un
mois plus tard en approuvant la clôture
du mercato comme on dit c'est vrai que
l'erreur est humaine
au final et du coup vous avez été
rétrogradé alors que vous étiez en route
pour les playoffs cette saison presque
inarrêtable n'y avait presque pas eu de
défaite sur cette saison comment vous
avez réussi à remobiliser l'effectif
pour ce match de survie en fin de compte
et où se jouer sur un seul match
c'est vrai que là il ya eu quinze jours
trois semaines
un gros boulot effectué par les couches
parce qu'il a fallu à motiver les gars
quelques-uns ne voulait pas jouer cette
coupe de l'america on s'attendait tous à
une à plaider notre cause en disant oui
effectivement on a en a fait une erreur
on voulait une sanction administrative
tu as les transferts financière pourquoi
pas il y avait tout un panel de
sanctions administratives qui pouvait
nous être imposée ils ont basculé
s'assure sur le sportif ce qui est une
nouveauté quand même malgré tout donc on
apporter appelle l' affaire n'est pas
fini on va porter un recours auprès du
comité national olympique
maintenant c'est vrai que le laps de
temps qui nous est accordée ne nous
permet pas de chambouler les phases
finales se bat france puisque allaient
plier ses jours dans la vienne le match
de barrage la semaine dernière le plus
haut de la semaine prochaine donc c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué au niveau du
timing
du coup est ce que par rapport à cette
sanction vous l'estimez disproportionnée
de votre côté vous avez vous sentez un
petit peu victime d'une trop un excès de
zèle peut-être de la fédération
complètement complètement
il ya eu un pour tous pour tous il ya
huit heures des cas la chiraquie un
règlement il est là il n'y a pas de
problème mais à 8 heures près on n'a pas
du tout influencé sur le déroulement du
championnat ce jour-là bon c'était pas
non plus le jour international etc
c'est laure denis coux 1 voilà sans lui
faire injure et vidal à grantham il est
important dans l'effectif n'a pas dit il
va sans dire que c'était un excellent
joueur c'est pour ça qu'on l'a fait
venir n'en n'a pas influencé directement
quand on n'a pas les licences soit
composition de notre équipe donc on
trouve effectivement la sanction est
complètement disproportionnée sa
première fois que ça arrive
il ya des rétrogrades rétrogradation de
clubs mais pour des faits beaucoup plus
important de violences et autres
en effet après des investissements et
autres mais jamais sur une faute
administrative et voilà quoi donc
continuer leur cours justement donc lié
à ce recours que vous avez formulées
auprès de la fédération française
est ce que si cela n'aboutit pas à cette
procédure vous comptez aller plus loin
bien sûr on va aller plus loin donc au
comité olympique qui va essayer de
concilier les nous les deux camps et si
le comité olympique nous donne raison on
n'est reste pas très bienvenu créatif et
autres donc là il n'est plus question de
revenir sur le malheureusement sur les
phases finales du championnat
on va demander des dommages et intérêts
parce que il ya des dommages intérêts à
voir cette erreur humaine en fin de
compte elle chamboule un petit peu tout
le projet d'une saison et bien au delà
puisque ça faisait un petit moment que
c'était engagé ce projet de essayer en
tout cas de tenter ce doublé championnat
ligue des champions
tout à fait enfin c'était même
l'objectif prioritaire c'était le
championnat de france a eu nos champions
s'est jamais contre qui on tombe et
c'est un chant théâtre ans on maîtrise
un peu mieux c'était l'objectif du club
c'était l'objectif d'une majorité de
joueurs qui malheureusement vont finir
cette année il avait resigné cette année
pour pour aller glaner l'année ce titre
c'est vrai que de tenir partie on était
un peu la bête noire de ce championnat
et voilà tout s'est arrêté à quinze
jours trois semaines et ess est bien
évidemment compliqué alors il ya une
actualité un petit peu plus réjouissante
sais que vous allez accueillir le final
four de la ligue des champions 2014
ici à elancourt et là ça va être d'une
tout autre dimension puisque il y à ce
titre européen qui est en jeu et vous
allez avoir un premier match face à
helsinki
comment vous l'envisagez cette première
rencontre décisive alors cette première
rencontre bas et on découvre un peu le
club c'est pas les femmes endurent ne
rencontre pas tous les week-ends se
faire donc on a commencé à regarder un
peu quelques vidéos il joue pas mal
j'avoue que j'aurais préféré rencontrer
belgrade les serbes
mais bon c'est tombé là sur la place une
équipe tient à peu près le même style de
jeu que vous jouez tout à fait non je
joue à peu près moitié moitié
quelques bons américains
voilà c'est une équipe construire au
sérieux voilà tout à fait et l'objectif
sur ce final force est évidemment
d'aller glaner le titre quand on est si
près de la coupe normaux et bien sûr
bien sûr on va essayer donc passé ce
match parce que là comme l' avantage du
terrain on a fait tout le nécessaire
pour accueillir cette cette finale fort
donc on aura davantage de terrain voyage
un peu moi parce qu'au début était prévu
que cette finale fort se déroule à
belgrade donc que j'étais un peu plus
anxieux oui après il ya eu le mans aussi
qu'il est le mordant et qui
malheureusement à cause de la coupe du
monde de foot le stade est partitionné
donc
donc voilà ça va se dérouler de 11 les
demi finales se jouent le 11 donc à 13
heures de vendredi en juillet au
vendredi en juillet où il fut long à 13
heures on aura dans nos amis des black
panthers de thonon les bains qui jouons
belgrade et nous à 17h30 en style singh
qui face à ce qui est tout à fait et la
finale dimanche 17h pour les passionnés
voilà vous savez tout merci beaucoup
j'en rêve de passer sur les 7,8 sport et
puis à très bientôt évidemment suivra de
très près cette préparation pour ce
final fort ce mercredi a été donné le
coup d'envoi vous le savez de la coupe
du monde de football avec le match
d'ouverture très attendu brésil croatie
une rencontre attendue évidemment avec
impatience par les supporters et
certains saint quentinois tirent leurs
racines du pays du football depuis
quelques jours m touche et se repassent
les grands moments de l'histoire de la
coupe du monde il va vivre le premier
match du brésil
ici à saint quentin en yvelines mais ce
professeur de capoeira part avec sa
femme et ses deux enfants pour belo
horizonte sa ville natale le 26 juin
prochain pour les huitièmes de finale
pour moi j'étais petit voilà pour voir
les autres coupes du monde sait ça
senard à l'avoir comme c'était
aujourd'hui pendent encore comblé l'ia
est en fait part exactement brésilien
pourtant ce qui commande tout la planète
les entrants d'y aller il était allé
voir cette coupe du monde qui ça sert à
les atteindre extraordinaire le brésil
organise sa seconde coupe du monde après
celles de 1950
si à l'époque la seleçao s'étaient
inclinés 2 buts à 1 face à l'uruguay en
2014 ce supporters ne voit qu'une seule
fin pour les coéquipiers de neymar la
star barcelonaise mes mains c'est un
excellent joueur
doc mais je ne pense pas que c'était
qu'elle lui il ya des autos si derrière
lui qui sont un testament du jour etc et
et vont donner 7h07 président dit est
sorti vainqueur de cette coupe du monde
si m touché vibrera pour la seleçao il
aura un oeil sur le parcours des bleus
mais en cas de finale brésil france
celui-là déjà choisi son camp on
sentirait bien on se base il pourquoi
pas comme j'ai dit un senior à cette
fois ses succès le brésil c'est dans mon
pays
il y a quelques jours l'édition 2014 de
roland garros c'est du tennis y est
c'est s est terminée vous le savez une
quinzaine qui a vu le 9e sacre
historique de rafael nadal nadal pardon
sur la terre battue parisienne et autour
de lui toutes les équipes de juge de
ligne officié comme tous les ans à
chaque balle échanges et parmi eux
olivier noah était présent au bord du
court rencontre réalisée avec patrick
jacques de dixmude juliette poussons et
sébastien combes cyril bonjour à vous
donc je vous remercie de nous accueillir
sur les courts de verneuil-sur-seine
vous avait officié lors de votre
huitième roland-garros cette année en
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
cette édition a été assez pluvieuse tout
à fait ça a commencé dès les
qualifications où on a été effectivement
dès le début embêter on n'a du même
étendre les qualifications d'une journée
ce qui n'était pas prévu
on les a terminées le samedi matin alors
que d'ordinaire ça se termine le
vendredi soir et puis effectivement dans
la première semaine ça a été ça a été
effectivement perturbé comment on
devient juge de ligne est arbitre en
général dans ce sport qu'est le tennis
alors départ effectivement pour devenir
juge de ligne à roland garros on est
d'abord arbitres personnellement je suis
devenu arbitre un petit peu par hasard
en fait à l'époque j'étais licencié dans
un club en eure-et-loir et ce club
organisait un tournoi au mois de juin
juillet et m'ont demandé un jour de
tenir une permanence à la buvette et
dans le jeu les faits puis ça mais je me
suis intéressé un petit peu là
rganisation ça m'a plu j'ai voulu passer
les diplômes et à l'époque parmi les
diplômes qu'ils avaient à passer il
fallait passer le diplôme d'arbitré
quand j'ai passé l'épreuve ça m'a plu
puis j'ai continué et puis j'ai essayer
de gravir pour aller les échelons pour
aller le plus haut possible et alors
depuis depuis une bonne dizaine d'années
maintenant où vous officiez sur roland
garros en tant que juge de ligne comment
on est sélectionné pour roland garros et
j'imagine que ça doit être une
une sélection drastique non ligue a
effectivement pas mal de postulants
alors que gc on postule aux alentours de
novembre décembre puis ensuite la
fédération avec la ligne des yvelines
fait 1
fait un tri fait une sélection dont
s'est basée sur notre activité à une
autre activité annuelle en tant
qu'arbitre donc on doit arbitrer en ce
qui me concerne un peu minimum une
vingtaine de matchs en tant qu arbitre
de chaise si possible en plus avoir une
expérience
enfin avoir de l'expérience courante en
tant que juge de ligne lorsque la ligne
des yvelines me permet de faire et donc
j'arrive à être à être sélectionné
j'imagine comme bon nombre des arbitres
et juges de ligne vous êtes où vous
étiez joueur de tennis a la base je suis
toujours joueur de tennis alors j'ai mon
petit niveau pour les connaisseurs je
suis joueur au milieu de 4e série
mais je joue essentiellement et est
uniquement même pour m'amuser donc et
prendre plaisir sur le terrain bien
entendu donc vous arbitrez depuis
quelques années maintenant vous avez dû
voir l'évolution du jeu sur les courts
un petit peu partout en france et puis
notamment sur roland garros en tant que
juge de ligne ça va de plus en plus vite
les joueurs frappent de plus en plus
fort notamment au service il ya des
services qui avoisine les 250 km/heure
est ce que c'est de plus en plus
compliqué justement d'évaluer les
trajectoires et de ne pas se tromper sur
une balle qui touche presque ou pas la
ligne pour être juge de ligne il faut
maîtriser un certain nombre de
techniques
donc chaque ligne un petit peu sa
technique spécifique et bat en
connaissances et techniques on arrive à
pallier la vitesse des balles le mieux
possible et à prendre une décision en
espérant toujours qu'elle soit la
meilleure bien entendu oui parce qu'il
faut le rappeler un évidement sur terre
battue il ya les traces qui vous aide
mais quand on est sur quick sur dur ou
sur green set là il n'y a pas grand
chose qui peut vous aider une fois que
la balle est passée
effectivement c'est pour ça que quand on
arbitre sur terre battue il nous est
conseillé on essaie de l'appliquer de
prendre toujours un petit laps de temps
supplémentaire pour pouvoir faire notre
annonce que soit la balle soit bonne ou
que la balle soit faute sans pour autant
prendre un temps trop important
mais sinon on essaye de prendre quand
même un petit laps de temps qui nous
permet de faire une annonce beaucoup
plus sûres donc vaut mieux une annonce
plus lente est meilleur qu'une valence
rapide est erronée j'imagine que le
jugement le plus compliqué c'est au
service parce que c'est là évidemment
que ça va le plus vite
comment vous faites pour apprécier les
trajectoires mais en fait on suit pas la
balle surtout pas en fait ce qu'on vous
fait c'est qu'on va regarder le joueur
initié son service
une fois que le service va être initiés
on va fixer la ligne de service et on va
attendre que la balle passe on ne peut
pas suivre la balle ça va trop vite donc
on attend que la balle passe et en
gardant la ligne dans notre champ de
vision
et puis une fois qu'elle est passée on
va faire notre notre jugement est alors
quand on est soi juge de ligne comme
comme vous êtes à roland garros où ou
sur la chaise aussi sur les tournois
nationaux
est-ce que c'est difficile d'être
toujours concentré à 100% sur son métier
et pas sur l' envie de regarder un beau
match par exemple il faut se détacher de
la fonction spectateurs effectivement
bon maintenant on sait que quand on
rentre sur le terrain c'est pas pour
être spectateur donc on fait on fait la
part des choses il ya des lignes qui
nécessite un petit peu plus de
concentration je pensais la ligne de
fond parce que la ligne de fond c'est
tuning ou vous n'allez pas avoir
beaucoup de balles très peu de balles
qui vont être très proche de la ligne
mais par contre au moment où la balle va
arriver et qui avait projeté de l'aide
il faudra vous soyez prêts donc c'est un
petit peu la difficulté de cette ligne
là ça m'est arrivé d'ailleurs cette
année d'avoir pendant 40 minutes sur une
rotation au qu aucune balle difficile à
juger
et puis d'un seul coup bah enfin de
rotation une balle qui est arrivé à
proximité ou sur la ligne je me rappelle
plus et bon bah là il faut être
il faut être présent il ya une autre
situation qui est toujours un petit peu
cocasse notamment à roland garros parce
qu'on le voit souvent c'est quand les
joueurs font des fautes de pied bat le
public se met à siffler je crois que
c'est une spécificité assez française
vous voyez alors effectivement n'est pas
très le public nous
je le reconnais en tant que joueur aussi
on n'est pas très familiarisés avec les
fautes de pied
c'est quelque chose en france c'est vrai
qu'il passe un petit peu au travers
maintenant à ce niveau là on peut pas se
permettre de laisser passer ce genre de
fautes donc dès qu'il y en a on le
signale et moi en plus cette année
j'étais sur la ligne de fond justement
donc j'ai été amenée ont signalé
quelques unes mais bon bah ça fait
partie de mon travail c'est à partir du
moment où le joueur initie son geste
jusqu'au moment où il frappe la balle il
ne doit pas toucher la ligne au niveau
professionnel c'est quand elle les
joueurs sont quand même assez habitués
le savent qu'on est particulièrement
vigilants sur ces photos là donc moi sur
celle que j'ai signalé en tout cas à
roland garros j'ai jamais eu de problème
juste demandé quel pied avait touché
vente seulement mais ça fait partie des
renseignements qu'on doit leur donner
pour que puisse se corriger dernières
questions j'imagine que maintenant vous
passez plus de temps peut-être en tant
que arbitres et juges de ligne que en
tant que joueur nancéen peu votre
seconde carrière qui est alors élégante
effectivement dans déjà l'activité par
elle même est un petit peu plus
prenantes parce que quand on est désigné
sur des tournois on y va pour toute la
journée
donc on fait des journées consécutives
alors que quand on est joueur au niveau
amateur on arrive pour notre match on
fait notre match puis on s'en va on
revient pour le suivant si on a eu la
chance de gagner
effectivement ça prend quand même moins
de temps en temps que joueur maintenant
quand on s'engage sur un tournoi c'est
souvent pour une durée déterminée
souvent c'est un week end entier un
minimum voire des fois la semaine quand
votre activité professionnelle le permet
donc effectivement ça prend plus de
temps que l'activité de joueurs mais je
tiens à garder en ce qui me concerne une
activité de jeux avec la raquette à la
main merci tout à fait cyrine nous avoir
accueillis ici sur les courts de
verneuil et puis bonne continuation pour
encore plein de jugement en tout cas
très bon sur les cours merci beaucoup
merci d'être venus en tout cas retenu et
le tennis à l'école a encore de beaux
jours devant lui puisque aujourd'hui
jean michel coignard directeur
académique et nos baies norbert rampo la
président de la ligue des yvelines ont
renouvelé la convention pour l'activité
tennis dans les établissements scolaires
et à l'occasion le collège de
feucherolles a été récompensé pour son
premier titre de champion de france unss
c'est le sport scolaire catégorie
excellence et le lycée
villepreux pour son deuxième titre
national consécutif 81 voiture
centenaire s'étaient regroupés ce
dimanche devant le château de
rambouillet pour la troisième édition du
paris rambouillet un rallye qui offre
une autre vie au mythe de l'asphalt
d'avant-guerre images de jonathan lynn
elle brille le bruit de leurs moteurs
ancestrale verse à nouveau les amoureux
de mécanique
pourtant pour la plupart de ces
véhicules leurs propriétaires les ont
bichonné pendant des jours des mois pour
qu'il puisse à nouveau des vallées
l'asphalt entre joël et sa renault eux
car l'histoire d'amour dure depuis cinq
ans fabriqué en 1914 ce bicylindre sans
électricité doit être démarrer à la
manivelle
je peux même presque dire qu'elle est
plus belle que quand tu as en sortie
d'usiné
parce que en particulier les peintures
les peintures à l'époque il ne
connaissait pas le passé que lepisto des
dons qu'il éprouve nature était pas au
pinceau et elle n'était pas aussi
brillante que vous les voyez maintenant
mais bon on se fait plaisir avec les
années les progrès technologiques
certains outils ont disparu et il faut
parfois les re créer soi même
une fois rénové et même par dose de
quelques centaines de kilomètres par an
s'asseoir au volant de ces voitures de
musées ne s'improvise pas on retrouve le
plaisir de conduire personnellement
c'est le plaisir de conduire une voiture
moderne on fait plus attention à ce
qu'on fait parce que tous les autoradios
et à les voitures boîte automatique maj
à tout va ce bien là accélérateur au
volant donc une fera débrayages
mais accélérateur au volant en l'espace
d'un siècle comme cette le zèbre de 1909
la plupart de ces mythes du bitume on
tue plusieurs vies une première sur la
route une deuxième dans les fermes ou
les châteaux pour tracter ou transporter
des marchandises et quand alan la chance
d'avoir subsister on les récupère nous
pour leur donner leurs 3e et là on
espère que c'est pour l'éternité parce
que vous pourriez à leur arrivée
maintenant rénover cette renault le cas
est évalué à 40 mille euros mais pour
l'instant désolé pour les amateurs elle
n'est pas à vendre
allez on passe à l'essentiel des
résultats du week-end
ce week-end se déroulait au stade rené
rousseau aux clayes-sous-bois les
finales de la coupe des yvelines de
football et parmi les résultats qui nous
sont parvenues chez les moins de 17 ans
menait 2 à 0 plaisir s'est finalement
imposé 3 2 face à montesson et chez les
u15 à égalité 3 partout après le temps
réglementaire versailles et au lion dû
se départager aux tirs au but victoire
finale versaillaise 4 tirs au but à 3 en
rugby petit air hatoum la semaine
dernière nous vous annoncions la défaite
de plaisir en huitièmes de finale de
fédérale 3 face à orléans 29 à 13
c'était bien un match décisif en fin de
compte sans confrontation retour plaisir
est donc éliminé de ces phases finales
mais verra les joutes de la fédérale 2
la saison prochaine
en cyclisme les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste 2015
reste encore à attribuer vous le savez
entre les candidatures d'aguascalientes
et de saint quentin en yvelines les deux
dossiers doivent être encore finalisés
notamment sur le plan financier pour
saint-quentin david lappartient le
président de la fédération française de
cyclisme a déclaré avoir un accord de
principe de différentes collectivités
mais le montant n'est pas encore assurée
pour rappel le budget de l'organisation
d'une telle compétition mondiale s'élève
à 2,4 millions d'euros le comité
directeur de l'uci réuni ce jeudi et ce
vendredi à lausanne s'est donné un délai
supplémentaire pour statuer sur
l'accueil de cette compétition de
décision rendue au plus tard le 30 juin
prochain de l'urban gueule ce week-end
on vous en parlait la semaine dernière
dans le 7-8 sport vous êtes certainement
essayer au street golf dans les rues de
saint quentin pour sa deuxième édition
l'urban golf permettait aux passants de
s'essayer au practice optique ou encore
aux approches le tout au milieu des
immeubles
l'objectif évidemment faire connaître la
discipline de façon ludique en vue de
l'accueil de la ryder cup 2018 au golf
national et pour certains il ya encore
quelques techniques à parfaire c'est
très bien c'est une très bonne animation
le buzz se démocratise petit à petit et
c'est justement grâce à
à ces petites manifestations qu'on
arrive à avoir de la promotion de leur
gueule j'ai jamais fait grève et là
c'est la première fois que je touche en
fait voilà à bavinchove et le petit truc
là la manette pour tirer et je trouve
que c'est ça m'a plus tard a beaucoup
plu toujours en cyclisme ce week-end se
déroulait du côté de rambouillet le
neuvième tour sud yvelines lors de la 4e
et dernière étape dimanche après midi
c'est laurent aubert qui s'est imposé en
solitaire avec 21 secondes d'avancé sur
ses poursuivants au général
cette course à étape a été remportée par
le neuilléen mathieu kalia après une 10e
place
pris dans le prologue samedi matin le
contre la montre par équipes dimanche a
permis aux coureurs de neuilly-sur-seine
de prendre le maillot jaune de leader
avant de contrôler la course dans la
dernière étape il remporte donc ce tour
avec quatre petites secondes d'avancé
sur son coéquipier frédéric besson une
grande satisfaction avec une power un
sacré combat ça frémit 10 notamment
contre le club devant je faisais très
fair-play une belle bagarre je suis très
satisfait d'en sortir vainqueur d'avoir
toutes ces organes de cette organisation
toutes ces personnes qui s'occupent de
nous pour heures c'est vraiment
fantastique ça nous donne un peu nulle
part de rêve
mais ça me permet de rêver un peu
pendant un week-end on passe un super
week-end de vélo de fait une dernière
info avant de nous quitter des nouvelles
de nos deux rameurs yvelinois à se
presser de jours et sept heures de
course sur la guilde pacifique cruijff
christophe papillon et clément et llory
giner de millemont dans les yvelines ont
réalisé une première semaine au maire
exceptionnel il pointe au 5e rang au
classement général et mène la flotte des
bateaux composé de deux rameurs je vous
le rappelle leur challenge est
gigantesque puisqu'ils doivent relier à
la rame et sans escale la californie et
hawaï soit environ 3900 km à vol
d'oiseau
c'est la fin de ce set 8 ports merci
encore une fois de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain même lieu même
heure d'ici là excellente soirée sur tv
fille